a visitor just anything I just want a
pitch yeah let you know pitch it you can
get me out suit you think you know me
consumer can do it's undeniably good
prompter yes not only do you want to
only give me a measly return investment
but you also want my advice for free as
well
no no so this is negotiable it's
business it would be but it is quick
cash this is like Dragons Den but the
problem says growing alone he acted like
he was prepared to do it but he was very
sad officer would you say yeah so what
did he say he was I don't pick I'm not
I'm a bad feeling
yeah yeah I think it seemed to be honest
I thought was a bit Robert yeah why why
he showed me he certainly showed you all
the numbers of the property the results
I don't think those due diligence
properly yeah visitor so it's John the
right ball to my book I'm not sure we
actually have something to do okay oh
yeah sorry
don't tell me to go quick just say
thanks so much I'll just say what I know
right I've just said I'll just basically
found a really good deal and I just want
to do it matter I just completely
obvious bro yeah I'm really sorry god I
just literally I saw it I thought it's
go get trained straight down here and
you know just see fingers he's doing man
same with the meeting
I just want to pitch yeah let you know
pitch it you can hear me out suit you
think you know we can see we can do oh
good
people come to my office of an
appointment I get sent home although I
do live with passion
it gets sent back here we are we the
meat in should we give them out what's
the day how would you take the pitch I
reckon I can do it in three minutes do
the figures they're already sore a
little ball he's come thank you
somewhere here you want to give us my
table yeah let's get this let's do this
[ __ ] come on yeah you know I'm just
winded you want to I advise quick give
us give us give us you pitch take your
jacket off will do by yourself the
cameras and stuff we'll just do what
we've got are we time in this three
minutes or might you go just drop that
daddy's shirt you can't be pitching
poverty deals without being miked up and
film man this this is going straight to
freaking YouTube but I never was gonna
see our rubbish you beer no pressure
this is you live in front of 10,000
people bro that's like what John you've
got some big
John with balls of steel God leads
headquarters to just barge it in to
picture pond heavy security all right so
this is gonna be serious now this is
Dragons Den star Mike you do the verbs
you're probably going to get thrown out
in the next three minutes property
property down so proxy dead tell us what
you want so I found a really really good
six bed hitchmo in yeah really great
figures basically got wall in front of
me got the different scenarios and I'm
looking for a 10 percent investment
I need 30 grand to get a the initial
deposit money together a template a
veteran 10% return on the money you give
me after a year's time so we're
basically looking so we've got I've got
different scenarios in front of me I'll
just quickly talk you through them so in
a good good scenario money in but you
know generally without this return if I
had the money we'd be looking at a 35%
pretty that's with obviously decent with
management of 12% maintenance and boys
if maintenance employees goes up to 15
management goes up 15 still looking at
29% of said worst-case scenario where
void 20% man from printers then you're
looking at 22% me too
so it's quite a safe investment for you
all so I can return your money with that
so I've also worked it out so you can
look at that the figures right front you
the highlight it is just showing you the
different scenarios and it says 10%
return obviously if I'd returned the
temp sent to you a year this is people
apart it obviously the 10% borrowing
rate it was still making really good
money so and they've gotten a good sign
a slow down a little bit because you
used to spouting off a lot of figures
and I want to actually take this in so
you keep going but just so fun I know
where this is you know where that is
yeah man
so it's not 290 2500 is that what you've
actually had a greed or whether yes
that's completely agreed
well it's to an agent to direct a vendor
it's through an agent that's a pretty
good price
yes you assuming the conditions okay I
mean what's the what's the value what's
the true market value so true market
value is about 105 sort of not least a
little bit but it would be to 500 you've
had secured so you've secured it but
does the agent know that you've not got
any money or have you just told them
that small not to do with the agent I
secured I've secured the deal or they're
kind of waiting for the proof of funding
that kind of thing so that's why it's
quite it and that's why I had to come
down I know the street I like the street
so it's current what's the current
situation what's the condition what's
the use of the moment current situation
clinicians good it's currently a 7 bed
but it's unlicensed and so that she
believed the vendor wants to get rid of
it quickly
I hardly hmm underground he says five or
six beds you know no planet from that
way it's easily licensed the balls who
is accredited right now it's time to
with five tenants I do a DSS current
license license yeah so but I have to
that's where you go cheap yeah I have
had a Haseman
I hate my buns around and I have used
what little you have got to get
electrical surveys and building surveys
they've all come back fine hate reminds
each other would you have them with you
or any information on the surveys I do
have the surveys with a shows about what
everything came back fine
yeah yeah everything came back fine with
those so basically we're good to go
I just need the investment money there I
was have to pay for an HTML license but
the agent managed has learned some
benefit okay it's undeniably
it's undeniably a goodness it's all good
yeah it's undeniably good property yes I
think so
the one thing is concerning me Espada as
soon as I saw these figures so the
minutes not licensed yes the minute it's
not licensed so is it being converted
law is it legally converted could you've
only put down two thousand pound reefer
oh no so technically everything is
legally done that the problem of Enders
got is she talked to Johnson's property
didn't really understand what she's
doing so with regards to the tenancy so
you'll see that I put cost of fine
attendance and tendency problems you
know sell the AST is incorrectly so we
discovered all this that's not answering
my question about the renovation cost so
no yeah everything's fine
room sizes you sighs I'm sorry the
property is in good condition looking at
what eyes they're saying is to turn it
from an illegal
Otis fired all spirals imagine loose no
tensions there it's so abuse all for two
thousand pound for two thousand pound is
just basically to open if the property
lot going to the hinge MC ends down time
you spoke to the local planning officer
look weeks morphs no brothers
I've spoken to yes Vince or thought my
spoken say H no and officer
the concern is you've it's unlicensed
it's illegal and you want to put factor
in to grant and if it needs to fireball
don't know if it needs if the Farallon
doesn't match the local criteria or
things out that it's that's gonna be
where a ballpark of course but I think
you've done your research I need to know
that I have spoken to sort of my a
channel s an agent who will be left in
the property he's been around you went
around yesterday that's all the reasons
I've come down Frank it's sort as
quickly as a half he said it's fine you
know there's nothing major needs to be
done well the surveys group you can see
the picture your pictures look nice and
you've been around the property
presumably yeah I very much enjoy doing
it without tenants presumably with what
I'm gonna do yeah problems the SDS
without surrender all the SDS yeah they
are more sore DSS housing benefit kind
of n so what we'll have to do is we'll
just have to restart the SDS and we've
got some initial terms to start with
what if we sell property in that
straight what you need planning
permission to turn into a seven better
yeah we that's what we think and say
my figures wife earlier worked out on it
being a 6 bed not needing Planning
Commission just needing to be licensed
aged man I mean personally I think I
really think you've done great I really
do but to give you 30,000 pounds and 325
pounds which is what you need yeah to
get 10% to some people that will be
great and if these guys want to invest
in you 10% they can do that but like
that is not attractive to me at all
point out to one side they say it was
attractive to me I don't know no how are
you gonna pay back that money what's the
part you're gonna be fine at once you've
got a point what's the plan so what the
plan will be is once we've generated
some money as I said to you even if the
six-bed start with yeah also generated a
bit of money in rent through data with
then gonna look at getting planning
permission to turn it into seven bed why
it currently has been brilliant Apple
currently self out illegally we're gonna
don't do it properly
yeah hunt Michigan everything that get
turned into a seven bed that's gonna
push the price right that pushes the
yeah so it's already BMV a little bit
not push it up then pushing the price
quite all I think in that straight 7 bed
with planning permission in good
condition yeah
Martin it'll be like one two five easy
yeah and I always used to call the money
out there and then I was in six six
twelve months of your investment in with
an important money out it's a good house
it's a good house - uhmm I'm just
confident you can get the good tenants
patient managers comment very well yeah
no I'm sure I just wanna make sure he's
done this special manager page my
manager is confident about good tenants
and with the scenarios are giving you in
front of you with different management
rates and different issues everything
still works out you've got proof from
them they're happy with this
yes yeah so once it's all up and running
and you've paid all the mortgage
interest payments because you just only
what you've done here yes you pay the
bills if I the manager companies you're
expected to be making a total of monthly
cash flow of a 1031 pounds per month yes
which is good I mean if we give you 10%
you're gonna be you're gonna be making a
return on investment of this at why more
than 10% I mean realistically if I was
to invest this with you and give you the
30 grand to get it going you found deal
I get that if I was to invest with you
what would be the max
return on investment you can get makers
10% okay I get I get 20% more sleep well
it's a thing uses are interesting what
did you come investors know so that we
art with his people are interested in
boss I would want to work with more
lacrosse professional if I've got any
kind of issues will be honest only do
you want to only give me a measly return
on investment but you also apply advice
for free as well no no so this is
negotiable as business as you know the
business very much out it probably in
property down but before I perform the
decision I'd love to hear what what I'm
thinking I'm concerned I've lend the
ether a grant right and then and then
you not be able to give me the money
back right I mean what I said what I do
is I've been fine what's the house what
about what about you but I couldn't if
if I couldn't be fine house we would
obviously have to look for a new
potential investor if you do the honest
thing again we borrow it to pay you and
then they'll being on the deal don't
even more than yeah yeah ok this is what
I'm thinking if you really want to go
here to this house you've already
started the bull wall you have done some
good work it is a good house I agree
with that I would buy the house hmm
not you so I own it so I'm not lending
you the money right okay however you've
done a lot of the work here so you can
carry on I'll let you manage it for me
and then we'll just got hard on the
profits mmm
so why don't you get a 50% right there
so if you how much you say you're gonna
make a profit every month profit-wise
you've been looking about a thousand
above a thousand pound it suppose you
put nothing in just a bit of work can
you make a 500 pound a month yeah
generally all scenarios that you've
worked out so good offer
you don't know house I own the house
because I not being funny but like if
I'm putting the money in I want to own
it I don't want to be lending the money
to you we can find deals like this all
day every day this is good yeah good
you can add that I I think that's a good
deal but I think Russell's taking
advantage of you a little bit what
number what it's a little bit man
because money he's fed the subject house
say I think this is a good house what
are you suggesting I'm stuck so you put
here is this worked out in a six big or
seven bit because here were times six
bed so the rental incomes on a 6 bed yes
let's make some super I'll buy it off
you
hmm I buy as I'll give you a finder's
fee for and I'll buy it myself right
obviously planning for it and I'm the
one taking advantage the what I'm the
one that's giving you five in Japan and
month look I've got cash here today
he'll make that back you'll make that
back we've market in six six months yeah
and then you would carry on making money
off it forever can I have something here
I wouldn't go through their deals
personally all I think we're the wrong
investors or on I fit your best option
will be what you came here for which is
you want someone to give you the money
and you want to give them tempis every
time that for you we're the best deal
why mind how much time we've got notice
all that well lots to talk about we
should pause the videos I want to give
you one ml up and in that hour here is
my best advice to give to you my advice
would be try and find someone smash the
funds you did that training yeah you do
that you've done the very poor nuts
friend yes yes right smash the funds
find someone that's prepared to give you
the thirty thousand pounds where you
give them ten percent fixed you'll be
able to give them that easy from this
deal right
right that is your best option if you
haven't do it within an hour come back
in and we'll see how they fill in there
right yeah
yeah oh good job man I've seen that ice
cream turnip it comes up actually now
finished right
yeah remove them get John back only what
I will do every raise the money or not
directly fine we can hopefully uh
hopefully Atari I did or I can eat it
yeah buddy be mental today you'll do it
would be bases quick cash maybe he
wanted yeah awesome right
effectively estate agents well as they
agreed Dominic you know they want some
hobby secure they do bring me turn sour
I've been ringing round I don't think
I'll get the sort of 10% return from the
investors in time every time yeah I get
it
but just not in the necessary time to
the okay what do you so I knew a little
age wise I mean that's yes good hard oh
I don't wanna lose it what do you think
of muscles are what I think it was awful
it's a good offer it's obviously giving
me like cash flows I hang it up but yeah
I've only dogs gonna give me cash flow
monkey well I mean how many people can
know but my payment up front line you
can get paid today does about any book
could have I would you found a mother
from doing howl did that determine how
much work did you take on that was a
huge amount maybe like a half a day just
worked out fingers Bobby
[Music]
so yes yeah yeah yeah I feel good
progress with we've got their money and
we can hopefully get a deposit on a half
yeah and you know what though we this is
like Dragons Den but the problems
brewing alone we should actually I think
John has pioneered something here we
should accept buy a property down
property down yeah because I don't
people barging in like this
and people gonna come in and they're
gonna know good deal if it's max in the
face I don't take these stupid deals
Academy members only property dad doing
a cab you remember you want
I'm a [ __ ] to us comment below if you
don't know what the Academy is comment
below of so your thoughts do you think
that John made the right decision don't
advise that until your government
whistle there's no your thoughts comment
below don't forget to subscribe share
the video this has it will be video
hasn't it Nick yeah oh yeah awesome god
bless you see you next time
[Music]